starting today he'll be giving another talk as
well he's done some a lot of his actual work on
some perhaps most prominent some
fascinating stuff that he's done with
james setna with information geometry and
the foundations of cisco imprints i guess
he also does a lot of work with biology and
at least non-equilibrium statistical physics
he's a uh so to speak purebred ivy boy brown to
cornell to princeton and now he's a professor
in physics at yale so you know he hasn't
been in any decent institutions but well
nonetheless um and if you're curious yes he
is um affiliated shall we say with john marta
external faculty both of them are now listening
here regularly and both of them are actually
contributing to community so as i think i
may have mentioned you'll be giving two talks
and this is the first event
thank you very much let's see
yeah uh thank you very much david it's a
wonderful visit a wonderful time to spend uh
my omicron um uh so this is actually the
first in-person talk i've given in two
years uh so this is very exciting for me
um and um yeah so i i will get into it um
there we go okay so um i want you to just take
this all in don't don't look too carefully
um what i want you to take from this is
that we really know uh an enormous amount
about biology's molecular details um so all the
circles there represent proteins in many cases
um we know their their structure um the arrows
represent interactions and those are things that
we really know about the system um some of them
are phosphorylation reactions some of them stick
to each other um and and these are all the things
that are going on inside of a t cell i'm not going
to be talking about t cells today um but but
maybe they're on everybody's mind a little bit
um and and for an example that i am going
to be going into detail about um here uh is
the the key components of a chemotaxis
pathway in e coli um i'm going to go into
more detail about all these players but but those
interactions are very well mapped and understood
um and in particular you can even read out the
phosphorylation state of that protein marked y
um you can do this in real time i'm going to
tell you a little bit about how that works
um and you get remarkable single cell traces
like this um so that that's what we know about
the microscopic details then you had you said we'd
get beautiful single cell information and then oh
yeah what's why yes what does that mean yeah so
i i will spend more time talking about this but
very roughly um that that protein marked with a y
gets phosphorylated so it gets chemically modified
um in real time um and you can track how much of
it is phosphorylated as a function of time using
a very fancy fluorescence tool um and this is
what the traces look like so you can see what um
in this case that that those five bacteriums
there are thinking about their environment
um this translates to whether
it's running or tumbling
yes um yeah so this is uh this is going to
be the signal that controls running tumble
um okay so that that's just a very brief survey
of how much we know about the microscopics
um we also know a lot about higher level functions
um so there there's a t cell that's attacking what
it's decided as a cancerous cell um this is a
an sem image um and then uh to go back to e coli
uh this is uh images of individual
bacteriums uh undergoing this run and
tumble napkin shouldn't it tell you about
so you can see they swim in straight lines
um and then they tumble and choose a new direction
okay um and and what i want you to think about
is how do you quantitatively connect these
um and and how do you connect this sort of
enormous amount of detail that we know at
the microscopic level um in a quantitative way
to um to these macroscopic behaviors um and i'm
gonna advocate for a reverse engineering approach
and the idea is that that you want a simple um
but quantitative model of the behavior um and
and and what you want from this is to be able
to identify what it is that makes this behavior
difficult um for for the organism to accomplish
um and what the needs are or the system
specifications for the molecular details
that are going to carry it out um and then
have quantitative models and measurements
at the microscopic scale that can try and identify
how it is that that these are men um and and the
goal is is really to try and understand the design
principles and and and how it is that biology
does these macroscopic behaviors
um through its molecular details
okay so i'm uh that that's the big framework
um but i'm going to tell you about two specific
projects um the first is using information theory
to connect chemotactic performance on any coli
really to the fidelity of their signaling
pathway so first i'm going to tell you
that a fixed information rate provides an
upper bound on how fast equilibrium chemotax
and then i'm going to talk about some experiments
where we can identify how much information
they get and compare that to the bound
and then the second part of the talk um i'm
going to talk about quantifying the energetic
costs of sending information um so um here's
one example that i'm going to spend a lot of
time on so a lot of signals are sent by uh uh
by depolarizing the membrane um and i'm going
to talk about how much energy this requires and
when biology should use different strategies okay
so um i'm going to start in with this
first part of the talk and tell you about
chemotaxis and how it's information
limited and i just want to start by
telling you about my collaborators so this
is a collaboration with with terry's group um
that i really started to get interested in
through talking with henry mattingly who i
knew when he was a grad student and i was a
postdoc now he's doing a postdoc with terry
um and and keita has developed this really
spectacular fret assay but i'll tell you that
okay so um so this is really about sensory
motor control um and to get you thinking
about it what's going on in this nature scene
here um these animals are taking in information
from their environment and they're using it
to control their muscles um and um and there's
really two things that are going on here so first
they're getting their sensory inputs and that's
controlling their motor behavior um but there's
also motor feedback so um so this is going to make
quantifying the information somewhat difficult
so for example um if if the uh cheetah there um
kicks its leg that that may change what what what
its eye sees but that's not really motor control
um and so we're gonna have to address this and
the very specific question that we're going to
be asking is do organisms efficiently use the
information they're getting to control their
behavior so um are they using all the information
that they get or using it in some sort of
optimal way or are they getting a lot of
information and then not using it well okay so
um i want to make an analogy to image compression
um so as you can see maybe depending on your
internet connection um they all look bad but
what you should see is that as you go from a to d
um these images get clearer um and one one thing
you could do is ask how how much information you
need to store in these different images um and and
and one way to frame this um is is with a curve
um that separates this into a forbidden um in
a allowed region um so if i plot image quality
on the y-axis and image size and bits on on the
x-axis um there's an allowed region so i can yeah
i i don't mean to derail you but don't you have
to define quality absolutely um i'm not going to
for this example right um people think a lot about
that here so so the y-axis is not an information
theory got it that's something that you need
to think about um our visual system perhaps
yeah um so actually this is this is harder
to do for this example than for chemotaxis
um yeah and so by forbidden you just mean
that that green curve is an upper bound
yeah so so if i want an image of of this
quality that takes this many bits i can do that
um if i want to make it
higher quality i can't do that
okay and and just shape this curve something
important or is it just this is just a sketch
um it will be it will be calculated um uh
uh when i get to the actual example but yes
um yes okay and just to stress this um
this is also possible right so in fact
um if you save a poor quality image in powerpoint
you often run into this i suspect that's what's
happening here but i don't know so so you don't
you don't need to be efficient but you could be
um and the question i'm going to be asking is
whether organisms um uh if we can make a curve
like this and then see where organisms sit on it
okay um so this is this is uh uh embarrassingly
enough i thought this was a microscopy image this
is um an animation which i still think is nice
um uh of the behavior that i'm going to be
talking about running flammable navigation
so these animated bacterium are are trying
to go towards the sugar and the way they do
this is they swim and they alternate swimming
with tumbling um here's the real thing here
um maybe you can see uh if you follow
the guy coming in from the upper left
tomorrow you can see he runs
in a straight line for a while
then tumbles and chooses a new direction
um and uh the reason that uh we're
gonna start with this is that this is
really the best understood behavior in
all of biology claim um it's very simple
um we know exactly what they're trying
to do um and and we really know many of
the components that carried out um and that
that's what i'm going to be telling you about
um but to give a an overview of all the things
i'm going to say here um the first thing i'm
going to claim is that we can draw a curve like
that image curve that i showed before but now
where the the drift velocity so how quickly um
these bacterium can climb a shallow gradient
is bounded um by their information rate um
with some additional factors um then i'm going
to tell you about our measurements to actually
calculate the information rate in these bacterium
um and then i'm going to ask the question of
how close actual bacterium are to this bound
okay starting with this
i'm going to tell you a little bit
more about the details of how they
carry out this behavior called
running tumble navigation um
so so they have two forms of motility one is this
weights straight swimming run that you see there
and the other thing that they can do is tumble and
the same motor does this when it runs in reverse
um these filaments splay out and they
choose a random new direction more or less
um and and and i should tell you why they do
this so one of their main constraints is that
they're very small so e coli are about two microns
long and the gradients that they'd like to climb
are are more in the centimeter range so one thing
that you could imagine they do is measure the
concentration difference between their two sides
um and swim towards the one that's more favorable
um and and you can sort of work out the math
for this and it doesn't seem promising right
that that there's just not going to be
a big difference between the two sides
another major constraint for them is rotational
diffusion um so they're small enough that thermal
fluctuations um will kick them in a random
direction and it turns out they can only go
in a straight line um for a few seconds at a
time so the strategy that they use to to climb
gradients is that they run in a straight line or
as straight aligned as they can um and as they do
this they continuously measure the concentration
and if they think they're going uphill or towards
attractants or away from repellents they keep
going um and if they think they're going downhill
they tumble they choose a new direction
and they and they swim in that direction um
okay and and just very qualitatively um this is
an example of sensory motor coupling right they're
taking in information from their environment
um they're using it to control the motor
um and you can convince yourself that with no
information they can't climb agreement right
ben yeah so there's an even simpler strategy
if there's some set point of high or low sugar
concentration which just says if it's if it's high
stay where you are and if it's low go somewhere
else yeah i i don't know if that's functionally
different from measuring the time derivatives
because presumably you would have to
change the sort of set point based on
your current environment but um i'm just curious
whether you know do we know that it's really
measuring derivatives as opposed to just levels
to the extent that's a well-defined question
yes um it's it's very clear that they're measuring
a derivative here um i'll show you the experiments
that so maybe maybe hold this question but one of
the really striking things about this system is
um that they can measure so um so you can
you can plug in how fast they go with a 10
millimeter gradient for example and they'll see
about a one percent change um in a typical run
so they do need to measure really tiny
concentration difference and this system will work
over several orders of magnitude of background
concentration um so in a certain sense they really
don't care at all about the total concentration
they only care about the rate of change thanks
okay so um um uh maybe to answer this
this previous question what what the
y-axis is going to be for this talk
is drift speed right and that's that's
that's the thing that's like image quality
but is much more easy to to carefully define
um that's what they're trying to do
that's going to be our performance measure
and the information rate that
we're going to use is how much
um the passive s t influences the current
decision of whether to tumble or not
okay so what what information does a chemotactic
bacterium need and i'm going to take you through
how we came to what we got um the first thing
we wanted to do is the mutual information rate
between the signal they're seeing um and and
i should say the signal is the rate of change
concentration and i think another thing that i
didn't say is we're always going to be considering
um uh uh just a flat gradient um i'm sorry for
i've already lost all the symbols what is s of t
yeah yeah sorry so smt um is
the instantaneous rate of change
of the concentration so that that's
that's what i'm calling the signal
um and m is the state of the motor
so the motor can even be running
um so the the the naive thing that we started
with was was the mutual information between um the
signal and the motor state and i think actually
the easiest way to explain why this doesn't work
um is is here so it turns out in this simulation
um there's no sensory motor coupling so they're
just running for a while they take a tumble um and
then they run for a while and they take another
tumble um but there's a lot of mutual information
between these so if i if i give you this curve you
can tell me exactly where the tumbles happen um
because that's when um uh uh you know that that's
when there are these sharp spikes right that's
that's when the bacterium chooses a new direction
um and so the mutual information does contain
sensory motor coupling but it also contains this
feedback from the motor system back onto
the sensory system sorry i'm going to ask
a really naive question can you find mutual
information yes um so the mutual information
is if i give you um two stochastic variables um
it's if i tell you the trajectory of one variable
um how much does that reduce the
entropy of the other variable um uh um
if
um generalization of covariance okay
yeah in terms of entropies rather than
square differences so coupled to symbolic dynamics
um i i could write an equation or two on uh
i don't i don't want to derail you now um
yeah i guess it's uh um this this was a good
explanation so if i have um um if i have
two trajectories the mutual information between
them is um exactly how much the um the entropy
of one of them is reduced if i tell you the
trajectory of the other um and and uh and i guess
from that definition if i gave you this trajectory
here um that reduces the entropy of the motor
trajectory right because whenever there are these
spikes here that's when the motor tumbles right
um okay um so this this um mutual information can
be larger than zero even if i don't have receptors
right so even if i'm not connecting sensory system
to the motor system um uh and and so somehow we
want just this part here um and and so instead we
use what's called the transfer entropy rate from
s to m um and um maybe i i won't go into details
about this but the total mutual information rate
um can be decomposed into a sum of
transfer entropies in these two directions
um and and and we just want one of these yeah
yes so somebody from the control theory world
would say this is a bayes optimal control problem
i would have a prior distribution over possible
gradients of concentration and i would
depending on my discounting rate into the future
i would come up with a policy that would actually
have nothing to do with information theory
but that would be in a bayesian sense today's
optimal control policy so why should i be thinking
about this in terms of information theory in the
first place yeah so um so so what a different way
you could ask or you could get something similar
as saying you know if if um if for example you're
counting molecules um people have thought about
um uh you know given the molecules that you've
seen in their time trajectory should you tumble
or not um uh what what we want to do differently
here is we want to understand how the sensory
apparatus limits how well you can do this if
that makes sense so presumably the sensory
apparatus can't literally count molecules
um um and that would fall into a standard control
theory of pid control or something like that
basically i mean all sensors
in the real world are noisy
the airplane that you flew to come out here
was based upon control theory where you assume
some noise in the sensors and you have models
of the noise yeah and so on and so forth so
i'm not quite sure why the peoria would
expect an information theoretic approach
rather than a bayesian decision theory
approach to be the right one to use um
yeah i'm not i i don't quite see how you
would get the um i would have to define my
objective function which would be pure amount of
um whatever the particular chemical is that the e
coli is trying to accumulate is yeah i think so i
think the the the objective function you could use
the same one that we're using which is just you
want to climb the gradient as quickly as possible
um um i guess what we're really after
is the question of of um uh is is the
limit on how well they can climb chemotaxis
but their sensory apparatus isn't better um
so i don't swear that there wouldn't be a way to
address this with it with a bayesian approach um
yeah
i don't quite see how it would all
go through but but it's possible
okay um so to to go a little
bit further with this um
uh i need to tell you a little bit more about
these behavioral parameters um and and what i
mean by behavioral parameters are these are
parameters um that are well-defined even um
if there's no sensory apparatus or no no gradient
sensing experimental if you put these bacterium
in in a solution that's just uniform um
and there are are these five parameters
so this is the rate at which the bacterium
tumbles um this is the average rate sorry um
uh uh this is the average rate at which you exit
a run and the average rate at which you exit and
tumble um alpha is is kind of the strength
of a typical tumble um so so so the the uh
literally the cosine of the angle between
the starting and initial uh directions dr
is a rotational diffusion rate um and and v naught
is the run speed um so um so these you can measure
for a bacterium that's not an ingredient they
don't require any information and then our model
um the only way that the signal enters is that the
rate at which runs are exited so the tumble rate
um is going to be some arbitrary functional of the
path of the signal if that makes sense so so um so
this can be some arbitrary functional the past the
signal um and then we're going to define i dot to
be the reduction in entropy of tumble decisions um
given that you know the test of s of t um if this
makes sense um so so this transfer entropy rate
what we're going to be using um is the reduction
in entropy of whether you make a tumble or not
depending on the past history of signal okay so
so once i specify all these parameters um that
gives a drift velocity and an information rate
um and then i can just optimize the drift velocity
um over these functionals and this gives a bound
on how quickly they can climb a gradient
as a function of their information rate
and this is what it looks like so there's
this pre-factor f of theta which depends on
these behavioral parameters um and then the
drift velocity is bounded um by this log 2
i dot over 12 dr this is the rotational
diffusion constant to the one-half power um
and um i will talk about these experiments a
little bit more um but um this this function is
bounded between zero and one so so the best you
can do if you choose your behavioral parameters
um is to make this one um and it turns out from
experiment this this number is about 0.5 um and
uh if i can explain why that is um the optimal
strategy is to set the the the tumble rate so
the rate at which you exit a run into a tumble to
be equal to the rotational diffusion constant um
so you want to tumble about as much as you lose
or about as often as you lose your heading from
rotational diffusion anyway um and it turns
out that these cells tumble way too much um and
that's a little bit of a mystery we and others
have some ideas so you you can argue for them
tumbling too much without these particular
methods um but maybe we won't go there for now
okay um so by measuring these behavioral
parameters um we really get this curve right
um and that lets us make a plot like this
um so on the y-axis now there's the drift
velocity divided by the run velocity um and on
the x-axis there's the information rate in bits
and and just to give one sort of mini-conclusion
already there's sort of a naive expectation that
um climbing a gradient in this way um you should
get about one bit per run right so every time you
run you should get some information about whether
you're going up the gradient down the gradient um
but but actually uh with a hundredth of a bit per
second and their runs are about a second um they
can already climb gradients at five percent of
their run speed um which is about how they do in a
okay so um so so far i've i've been
arguing that that the information rate
the information that comes into their sensors um
places a bound on on how well they can chemotax
um and uh and and what i want to spend
the rest of this part of the talk doing
is is placing e coli on this map so um so
so so where do they sit on this are they
um like these well compressed images
that they're they're close to this bound
or are they very far from it so they're getting
lots of information but not chemo texting well
okay um so now i'm going to tell you a little
bit of a detour into what we know about how
this pathway works um so um so uh at the
at the front of of the cell um there's a
sensory apparatus that's composed of a bunch of
receptors um uh and the receptors for attractants
um inhibit a an enzyme a chemical kinase um
that's called ka here um and when qa is not
inhibited it phosphorylates this molecule key
y um and qi diffuses to the motors and when it
binds to the motors it tells the motors that they
should run in reverse and that initiates a tumble
so in that sense um when there's not enough
attractant around or when there's a repellant um
this pathway sends a signal to the motors um that
tells them they should initiate a tumble um um
okay so there's there's really two key features
of the system um and and you can see them here
um so in this experiment um attractant
is applied just at this blue arrow here
um there's uh uh this readout um i'll tell you
a little bit more about in a second but you can
think of this as measuring what fraction of ty is
phosphorylated um and and what you can see is when
when attractant is applied um this signal drops
because the cells interpret this as as they just
you know swam into something good um they
should keep going in that direction um
but if you wait for long
enough the signal goes back up
so you know they've been there for a while
now and it's not still getting better
and then if you take the signal away you get a
huge spike they think they've just run downhill
um and they try and turn around and reverse
it does that make sense um so um this pathway
is really taking a derivative um and and uh
there's a lot understood about how this works
um in particular there's these two enzymes um qr
and qb which methylate the receptors and actually
change their affinity for ligand in real time
um and this this mediates perfect adaptation
so whatever concentration of ligand you put them
in they will come back to the same steady state
and uh and very roughly the key a concentration
or the key activity um you know how quickly
these are phosphorylating represents um e
coli's best estimate whether they're going
uphill or downfield not of their current
concentration does this sort of make sense
um so what we want to do is
estimate the information rate
um to key a during gradient climate so we
want to understand how much information
um does the key a signal get um about d log c d t
okay um so uh uh in the low signal limit um
you can actually estimate the information rate
um and and you can write it very
compactly in frequency space
um so the information rate is this integral over
frequency space of of the signal strength um times
uh uh the kernel between the the signal um and
the output so that here is going to be the key a
divided by the intrinsic noise in key
a so this is a signal-to-noise ratio
um and this one over four pi um comes out of
a more careful calculation okay um and and
to really measure this for e coli we need three
things um one is is k of t this is the kernel um
between uh a step change in concentration um and
the response of the kinases um that's k of t we're
going to have to measure that um we also need to
know the signal statistics s of omega or the auto
correlation of the signal that they see um and
then we also need to see the noise correlations
okay and i'm going to explain
how these are all calculated
um and um to do this i want to tell you
about this um really remarkable fret tool
um that that cada has developed um so this is the
microfluidic device these are not real bacteriums
um but but the the e coli are glued to the bottom
of this cover slip um and what cada can do is he
can change uh the concentration of volcanoes
that they see basically in real time and while
he's doing that um there's a fret reporter um
and and the way that works the the molecule that
that dephosphorylates key why um so so brings it
back to its steady state um uh you can attach um
uh one one color of fluorophore to that and
a different color of fluorophore um to key y
and then if they're in close proximity um the
spectrum of light that they emit will change
um and by doing this you can see
how associated they are in real time
so um in the experiment um which you can
see here um what keda does is he alternates
um increasing the concentration
um that's these red bars here
um and decreasing the concentration um and and
as he does this he can look at individual cells
and see how they interpret the signal in real time
and from this um he can infer a linear kernel of
how a step change in concentration um maps to the
dynamics of that makes sense um these are really
individual cells and individual times um but by
averaging um you can get a nice smooth curve like
this um and and this is really well fit by by two
exponentials there's a rise time and a decay time
okay the other thing we need is is is the noise
spectrum um and to do this um he just puts
these same cells in the same
setup i'm just in a constant
background and just looks at
their intrinsic fluctuations
there's a really a time you could notice
about these experiments i think they're
super interesting these cells
are really each kind of unique
there's a lot to go into here um but the
short version is that you can extract an
auto correlation curve of kindness activity
and it's actually pretty well fit with a single
exponential um so so individual cells have a lot
of variation which maybe is interesting um but
um but it's pretty consistent with with
just being fit by a single exponential
okay and and one of the things that
actually makes this system really unique
is that um and i think is a limitation for a
lot of studies of information theory in biology
um is that we actually also know the signal
statistics um and um and that's because
unlike in most systems the signals that they
generate or the signals that they see are really
just generated by their motion in a gradient
so recall that what we're calling the signal
is just the log c dt um and if they're in
an exponential gradient with steepness g
um the signal then is just the x component of the
velocity right um and and so if i want to know
um the auto correlation of sigma as a function of
time um uh all i need to do is measure their uh
correlations and velocity as a function of time um
and multiply it by the gradient uh steven squared
okay and and this um i'm sorry but uh probably
you're assuming that the the tumbling motion yeah
the tumbling motion that never makes a mistake uh
no so so actually the way these experiments work
they're put in a dish that doesn't have a gradient
um and they're just tracked as they swim around in
the gradient or in the lack of gradient sorry um
and from that you can measure the autocorrelation
of their velocity so okay um and the assumption
is that in a very shallow gradient um uh this
would generate a very weak signal right um and
and that's the signal that they would see so
those those um there's a linearization assumption
that um that their swimming statistics and the
absence of gradient would be roughly similar to
their swimming statistics open a shallow gradient
um okay so this is what
individual tracks look like
and from these you can calculate a velocity
autocorrelation function there are some caveats
here also this this autocorrelation function
actually doesn't look very exponential um and um
and one thing that that we don't really
have the ability to do is know whether
a single bacterium's um autocorrelation would
really be non-exponential um or if the reason
the average one is that there are different
cells with different tumble biases
uh so that there is a lot of
heterogeneity in the population
um and um we we don't have the ability
to test this but um what we assume
is that the average cell really would uh have
exponential correlations um and that's what we use
okay so um so i've i've told you how we
measure um these three things now right and
um and this this lets us calculate the information
rate um that these bacterium would see um in a
shallow gradient um and and the result um is that
the information rate can be summarized as this
constant beta um times the gradient squared um so
so um the signal statistics have this factor of g
squared in them um and in a shallow gradient we
expect this to be the information rate um and and
that makes a prediction um for for the information
rate as a function of the gradient seediness
okay
and um just just to give one more
data point here in a 10 millimeter
gradient that's sort of the the shallowest
gradient that people do these experiments and
these cells would get about two
thousandths of a bit per second
okay so finally i want to ask
whether e coli or information limited
so in the first part of the talk i i was saying
that that the drift velocity is really bounded
by some function of the information rate and now
we've calculated the bound and this information
rate and now we just need to check whether
they're close to it and just to stress this
the bound could be far from saturated right so
it could be that um the key a signal is really
getting a lot of information about the environment
but it's not using this effectively to chemotax
or it could be that the bound
was very close to saturated
right um and and and just to quantify this we
can talk about the efficiency which is really how
close um actual cells are to this bound here okay
um uh it turns out that measuring climbing speed
and a very shallow gradient is actually quite
difficult um uh these are uh uh there's a lot of
of details that i am probably poorly equipped to
explain about how to generate a very stable very
shallow gradient um uh and there's also issues
about making sure that what you're not seeing
is just that if you start all the cells in one
area they'll start to move towards the other area
but at any rate we could do this and and so
there's spread both in the x and y direction
where i should really say that henry did this
um and and from this um you can see that that
these are all in the shallow gradient regime and
that we can pull out this chemotactic coefficient
which is the linear constant that describes in
the shallow gradient um the relationship between
the climbing speed and the gradient um so now we
have these two different functions of gradient
steepness one is the drift speed and one is the
information rate um and these two y-axis are are
the x and y-axis so this plot um and so now we can
put cells on this um and and here's where they are
um and and and this suggests an efficiency of
about 65 um so yeah so this the efficiency i
guess i have two questions yeah as you just
alluded to is this the efficiency with which
the cell uses key a or also the efficiency with
which ka observes the gradient that's one question
the other question is and forgive me because i
think the answer is implicit if i watch the talk
again but are you optimizing just within run
and tumble strategies or is this really within
other motility strategies like what if they were
arranged like little fish what if they you know
did smoother changes in direction and so on um
okay the second the second question has an easier
answer which is that um this is all in the context
of of this run and tumble modeler that we have um
so for example you could ask whether steering
would be helpful um and there's good reasons to
think that that's not feasible for for bacteria
but that's not something we can address here
or it's at least it's not something we have
addressed here um um and i think there's
good reason to think that they really don't
steer they just run they tumble um because
i guess for similar reasons of being too small
to measure it's also hard to know whether turning
left or right is better um um the other question
is about what what this is the efficiency of
um and what i would say is it's it's given how
much information kia gets and we don't have
a good understanding of how much it could get i
would have more to say about that actually um but
given how much it gets how quickly could it climb
the gradient um so for example it could be that um
that um though pa has a very good measure of
whether they're going up or down um this isn't
communicated well to the motor and the motor
is just tumbling randomly right um that's what
would be low efficiency um another thing that
would be low efficiency actually is if um um
uh if qa was getting information but
the information was already out of date
so so our information measure includes information
about what the gradient or what what the um
you know what the x component of
the velocity was 10 seconds ago
but that's not actionable anymore for for
chemotaxis um and actually so this efficiency
is a combination of those two things right some of
the information might not be good and some of the
information might not be getting to the motor
and we can't we can't really distinguish those
um i think that was your first
question in its entirety awesome
um okay so just to conclude this part um equal
i need very little information to chemotax so um
something like a hundredth of a bit per run much
much smaller than the one bit that you might think
they also get very little information so in a
shallow gradient they have this huge apparatus
and it's trying but it's not
getting a lot of information
and then i think this is very different
from the usual information theory analysis
um so so what's often done is is is calculating
how much information a system gets and and i think
um here what we're trying to do is is instead
ask how the signaling fidelity really limits
the behavioral performance um i don't know if
this is getting at all but your earlier question
um so this isn't anyway maybe uh all right
yeah i mean i would think to be honest
the reason you're getting an answer that's a
factor of two off is because the bacteria is
actually to reproduce is facing a bayes optimal
decision theory problem and whether that can
be approximated with an information theoretic
framework or not is a another question but i would
almost say it's total logical that that's what
it's facing and i might explain the background too
yeah so so as in there could be other things that
it's trying to also optimize is ultimately going
to be interested in something like a reproductive
fitness which is going to have to do with how long
it's going to be surviving how much of whatever
it is that's trying to accumulate it can be using
to what actually reproduce are it's going to have
to do with the distribution of environments it's
likely to encounter so i have one one thing to say
about this um i mean maybe two things one is that
one thing that's sort of nice about this system
is that it does seem that it's really designed
to climb gradients so so um um that that seems
to be what most of the information is for and
actually um it climbs gradients for many different
things um this very simple idea that it's just
trying to get to food is probably um not its main
job okay you could make the objective function be
chrome oh we can talk about this offline yeah
whatever the objective is yeah but maybe another
thing that that um that that is interesting and
speaks to this um uh they tumble too often and
uh and there's various explanations in the
literature about why this is the one i find
the most compelling um is that they're actually
read not to chemotax in liquid um but but they're
put on auger plates um and actually in auger
plates there's this additional problem that
if you just swim in a straight line you get
stuck a lot and and and the idea is that
on auger but not in solution where these
experiments are done the optimal strategy
really is to take more tumbles so that you avoid
getting stuck um and i think it's a fair point
that that they could be optimized for things
like that that that are not in this setup um
well you only have ten minutes first part two
so see i think i'm gonna ask another question
uh okay maybe i maybe i will go quickly to
part two um okay so um so the second part
of the talk um and it will be shorter than
the first part of the talk um uh this is
uh work work done by by sam um the phd
student with me who will be graduating soon um
and um okay so um the big question here is
what what does biology use its energy for
um and samba goes towards wasted work um i won't
show this video again in the interest of time um
but for example um e coli needs to spin this
propeller um to move itself um uh and uh and when
you hike uphill you generate a lot of heat right
which you don't get back when you walk downhill
um and and this is really in the purview of
thermodynamics right um um but i would argue
that some of this energy is really going towards
um information processing very loosely defined so
i don't mean anything in particular here um except
maybe things that don't fall into this category of
of thermodynamic wasted work um and just for some
examples um we spend a lot of energy proofreading
molecules so so making sure that um dna is copied
uh accurately into more dna and rna and proteins
um also synchronizing molecules and what i'm going
to be talking about today sending information
and these costs are large so our brain consumes
a lot of our energy um and much of it is actually
used just towards pumping ions across the
membrane um so you spend a lot of your energy um
pumping sodium out of your neurons and pumping
potassium into your neurons um and the only
function that this serves um is is that it
opens a channel for very fast communication
okay so information has to be sent over
a lot of scales um in this problem that
i've or that that i've been telling
you about um information needs to get
from the sensory apparatus at the nose um
to the motors about a micron away and it
needs to get there in about 100 milliseconds
um in neurons information needs to be sent
um more like over a millimeter and
this has to happen in milliseconds um
and um and one thing you could ask is is what's
what's the fundamental cost to sending information
um and there's sort of a fundamental cost
depending on uh how you think about it so um
copying information is free but erasing
it costs energy and this would suggest
sort of a kbt per bit cost of sending
information why stop being free
um i think this is the usual picture of land
hours right that i can copy information for free
but then if i want to erase it um that costs kvt
abt log 2 for bit um depends whether by copying
you mean overwriting something which might have
had a bit before as opposed to yeah yeah so so
in many cases the copying and the erasing is
done at once and then you have to pay um and i
um if you're saying that that in this example that
would always be true i would agree okay um so i
would say um there's a fundamental cost which is
something like kbt for a bit to send information
um but what i wanna argue is that this is
in any case very far from the actual cost um
and and what i wanna ask is there are
practical costs that we can understand
um okay and and uh to explain this um i also
want to say that in addition to being sent over
a lot of different length and time scales there's
also a lot of diverse physical mechanisms um so
for example there are electrical signals where
ion channels mediate currents which depolarize
distant parts of the membrane and then you
have sensors which look for that depolarization
um you also have diffusion of second messengers
so key why the molecule that was a central part
before it gets phosphorylated and then
it diffuses to different mechanisms
to different sensors um and then we use sound
right so so um uh we use our vocal cords to
generate sound which travels to your ears um uh
where it's detected by specialized hair cells
um and there are some people who claim that
cells use this also um and uh and of course
this is not an exhaustive list but the questions
i want to ask are what determines what strategy
cells use when and what is the minimum energy
that cells could use to send information
okay how do we understand the order of magnitudes
this cost and and the hypothesis is that basically
all these things do the same thing right they
send information from one place to another place
um and the strategy should be chosen to minimize
the cost of sending the information and and that
here is going to be the energetic cost and and
the optimal strategy could depend on how far you
want to send the information it could depend
on how fast you want to send the information
and it could depend on how large you're
willing to make your sender and your receiver
um and and just to stress this um these
aren't fundamental bounds that i'm going
to be talking about these are bounds that
really reflect the reality of biology that
takes place and sort of form salty water
um carried out by biomolecular machines
okay so i want to let's see um uh if i spend five
more minutes is that okay um yes of course okay
cool um so let me just quickly tell you how
electrical signaling works so the medium
through which the signal is sent is that the
cytoplasm is a conductor it's an ionic solution
and the plasma membrane is a capacitor and and
you spend an enormous amount of energy pumping
sodium out and potassium into the cell um and this
accomplishes two things so first it maintains um
a constant voltage gradient across the membrane um
so the inside of your cells are negatively charged
compared to the outside but in
addition to this voltage gradient
the pumps maintain chemical gradients
um and the reason they do this
um is is so that an ion channel can open and
send a current in either direction so if i open
a channel to sodium ions that will depolarize the
membranes because there's a lot of sodium outside
if i open a potassium channel that will
hyperpolarize the cell because potassium
is at very low concentration outside um and so it
will flow out and these signals are received by
mostly voltage-gated ion channels um which
sense the local voltage across the membrane
okay so the setup we're going to be thinking about
um the input is going to be a physical current
um in particular for the case of ion channels
we're going to assume that that what an ion
channel can do is it can mediate a time dependent
current which is gaussian shaped around its origin
some radius sigma and the receiver is going to be
some channel that's that some distance away some
distance r away and what it's going to measure
is is the charge density is a function of time
um uh over a similar gaussian of size
sigma output um so that's the setup
um and we're going to be calculating
um the cost of sending information
through this physical channel okay so um i'm gonna
go quickly through uh the the details here um uh
but the things uh that we're gonna need
to calculate are the response function so
if i let in a little current at time t here
um what's the greens function of that at the
the receiver um and i'm also going to need to
calculate the noise spectrum at the receiver
um i'm going to use the same function for
the information rate that i had before
and the other thing that i'm going to need
now is a dissipation rate um so depending
on the power spectrum of the input i'm going
to need to know how much power that takes um
and then uh what what what you should notice is
that both the information rate and the dissipation
rate are integrals over frequency space um that
both have this input power spectrum in them
um and so by dividing the integrand what
i can come up with is a signaling cost
which is really a cost per bit um to send
a signal through this physical channel
from the input to the output okay and and
to calculate this i need the transmission
coefficient um the dissipation function
um and and the noise function the receiver
okay so um the dynamics for lambda are actually
pretty interesting um because charge is carried
for the the currents are carried through three
dimensions um but charge can only pile up if the
membrane um um maybe i won't attempt to give too
much intuition for where this comes from except
um that there's two physical content
constants the conductivity and the capacitance
and and once you have these dynamics you can
easily calculate the susceptibility um you can
also calculate this dissipation function and
and and there's many ways to do this but one
is to just calculate the dissipation through
the bulk resistor um as you send the signal
um and then to calculate the noise um we make the
very strong and and no doubt incorrect assumption
that the dominant noise is thermal um there's
certainly no getting around that noise um and then
uh with this we can calculate the noise spectrum
using the fluctuation dissipation relations
um and the end result of this is a cost
um in the form of of kbt per bit uh to
send the information through this channel um
and uh uh and it has this particular form so
the cost increases is the square of the distance
um the cost is also inversely proportional
um to the size of the sender and the receiver so
a larger sender has less resistance and so it's
easier to send and a larger resistance sorry
larger sensor can better detect small signals
and then it's cut off with this universal
function uh of of the ratio of the distance
you're sending it um to l of omega and i have to
explain what that is um so if r is larger than
this the cost rises exponentially um l of omega
it turns out is alpha over c uh and i'm sorry
omega is at the bottom there but to explain it
um you're probably used to thinking of an rc time
yes um okay so here alpha over c is an rc speed
um and you cannot send the signal faster than
this without paying an exponential cost um so
um okay so you could also send signals through
two-dimensional diffusion and three-dimensional
diffusion um i'd be happy to chat more about this
after um or through sound um and and and um maybe
i'll end by telling you about the space diagram
um for when you should use these different
strategies um so if you want to send things over
short distances um you should use diffusion
if it's slow you should use 2d diffusion
and as you want to send things
faster and over longer distances
you should start using
electrical and eventually sound
um okay um maybe that's a good place to
stop um i'll put my conclusions up here
um uh and uh i'll stop for questions all right
we asked a lot of questions during
the challenge people who need to leave
i'm not just feel free i'm gonna get a lot
of questions asked do we have any other one
for those your students who put
the box on the lower right yes
but mostly
and the other talking